Welcome to the time variance authority i
miss minutes and it's my job to catch you
up before you stand trial for your crimes
so settle in now hang on just a minute
and we'll get you in front of a judge in no time
who actually believes this crap
i'm going to see your ticket no
thanks for visiting the tva don't
hesitate to let us know how we're doing
what do you want from me you
put our timeline in chaos
I want you to help us fix it what could
possibly go wrong trusty loki is not a good idea
do i get a weapon gear up ah
don't those absolutely not
original series streaming wednesday
june 9th only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone we have a brand new loki
trailer breakdown from episode one this is
basically the opening scene there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs here with some footage from later
in the episodes i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all those videos and we're
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about what's actually
going on during the loki series so i love the
way they opened this trailer with them opening
the doors to the elevator and then taking him
to the processing queue and you actually hear
the voice of miss minutes and we get a little
more information about what's actually going
on with her as i predicted she's sort of like the
jarvis ai that they're using to run a lot of these
systems and you can kind of see her in all these
monitors here processing loki as he comes in like
welcome to the time variance authority but then
you see him getting hauled in right after they
capture him holding the tesseract like later in
the trailer you actually see him walking around
these rooms inside this office here with all these
people shuffling paper and looking at the timeline
on these monitors and he's still holding the
tesseract in his hand i love the imagery there
like he's so dumbfounded and has no idea what's
going on and is kind of afraid so even though
he's holding an infinity stone in his hand he has
this amazingly powerful item he just doesn't know
what to do with himself he's so confused then
he sort of gets the same type of dressing down
scene with them processing him and putting him in
those prisoners clothes the same way that thor got
processed at the beginning of thor ragnarok so
you probably sent some parallels here whatever's
going on with this machine here i love the fact
that it seems like it's intelligent and it's like
frowning at him as it's trying to take all of his
clothes off and push him down to the next floor
and loki just can't stand it like hang on a minute
just wait a minute before you take all my clothes
away that they might be cutting this kind of funny
but the way they're implying is that they just put
the clothes on him as he's falling to the next
floor and they get ready to process them through
this door here even if you don't live inside
the united states every country has a version of
this type of governmental office that you have to
stand in some epic line and it's the most terrible
experience ever then typical loki he just tries
to turn it into this big joke like you expect me
to take this seriously this is all just completely
ridiculous and they do another thor ragnarok style
scene where he watches another dude get melted or
really vaporized in this case it's just like the
scene of thor being processed in ragnarok he comes
through that willy wonka style nightmare scene and
is completely confused about what's going on then
immediately turns to watch the grand master melt
someone with his quote-unquote melting stick
someone bringing me my melting stick and they
just turned to this big comedic scene of him being
grossed out remember this version of loki did not
experience the events of ragnarok he just came
from the events of the first avengers movie like
he just got thrashed by the hulk you can read some
of the text on the monitors in the background here
it just reads time bears authority's logo and then
underneath it says four time always as if that's
part of their motto but then underneath that there
is more text it's just a little too small to read
so we'll have to wait for the actual episode maybe
we'll get a close-up of that we get another really
good look at the time keepers citadel at the
end of time only this time it seems like the
scene is happening at night or maybe this is
just exposed to space and that's what we're
seeing the blackness in the background then this
is probably part of that scene of him being judged
by rennslayer here Gugu Mbatha-Raw's character you
see mobius in the back of this courtroom here so
he's probably been monitoring loki ever since he
arrived at the tva and just kind of watching this
play out waiting for his opportunity to come
up and advocate for him they intercut a couple
different scenes like them going to this roxanne
version of a walmart like roxcart is from later
in one of their missions that they go on but then
you see him walking around a couple of the other
buildings in the rooms inside the time variance
authority just learning about these things
as mobius narrates the stakes of the series like
you broke the timeline really badly we need you to
fix it now this room is just designed to look
like the rooms that you see in the comic book
version of the tva it's just like rows and rows
of desks that go on for forever very hitchhiker's
guide very doctor who like the bureaucracy from
hell this scene of the path of the energy arcing
around this giant planetoid or this asteroid here
seems like it's either the bifrost or the path of
the tesseract the space stone as he's trying to
escape the tesseract and the bifrost basically
open wormholes through space or the space stone
is what's doing all the work it's just inside the
tesseract so the wormholes themselves don't have
to be straight lines they can curve however you
want them to it's just that we haven't spent a ton
of time in the thor movies showing that because
it's usually just scenes of thor and other people
leaving to go somewhere like point of departure
or showing him arriving like the epic avengers
infinity war scene with him coming to the battle
of wakanda still one of the best scenes from that
movie the funny thing about this scene with him
with the daggers going up against judge rennslayer
here and these other troopers seems like it's
actually from later in the series or later in
the episode after he's gotten his daggers back
because they do have that funny tag scene at the
end of this trailer where they're heading out on
a mission and they're in the locker room here
and he's like do i get any weapons and mobius
hands him his trademark daggers but then that same
giant trooper who hauled him in in the first place
is like hell no you don't get a weapon and joins
them back love the setup here where loki is like
what could possibly go wrong and then they show
you a bunch of things going wrong this fight scene
of loki seems like wherever it's happening
is designed like an m.c escher painting with
these staircases just twisting around all over the
place and i'm sure these mass troops he's fighting
belong to an alternate version of himself another
evil loki that he's trying to stop but i can't
tell which designs these troops are based on from
the comics they seem like they're part of the same
force of troops that loki is fighting in this
green loki-themed fortress here like obviously
this belongs to an alternate version of loki there
are a couple creepier darker looking structures
that he approaches during the other trailers like
some of the alternate loki's are more comedic
versions like president loki seems hilarious in
this alternate version of post-apocalyptic earth
but some of the versions he goes after will
probably be more evil more twisted they've only
shown us a couple of the alternate loki's there's
a lot of rumors about other even crazier versions
of loki that we'll see during the series but some
of these structures do seem more traditionally
asgardian in their design so i'm assuming that
means we'll visit a couple different versions of
asgard in these alternate timelines like in this
one we actually see him inside odin's throne room
and it's just meant to be another version of him
ruling over asgard like he did at the end of thor
the dark world or the end of the first thor movie
before thor came back only the implication is is
that in this timeline something's gone seriously
wrong otherwise they wouldn't be trying to close
it down the whole idea being that as terrible
as loki seems as much of an antagonist at the
beginning of the series he's on his hero's arc
he will slowly eventually become a good character
i am so curious to see what happened in this
timeline where it seems like earth's moon has
cracked apart like something crazy has happened
then they end with that db cooper scene with him
jumping out the back of the plane and the bills
flying out of his briefcase that's a big reference
to db cooper in real life who if you're not a big
true crime fan it's actually this very infamous
case where he hijacked an airplane in midair in
the early 1970s stole a bunch of money and was
never caught so there were all kinds of theories
about what happened to him the authorities were
only ever able to find a couple of bills that had
fallen in the flight path of the plane itself so
they assumed that he had jumped out the back of
the plane into another plane or somewhere else or
parachuted somewhere else but in the united states
it's one of the more famous unsolved heist cases
so i know a lot of people are wondering if there's
some grand twist or revelation that they're
building up to with the time keepers because of
the way they presented that last big scene that
they dropped i did a video for it so i'll link it
at the end of this while mobius is busy trying to
teach him all about the time variance authority
what they do why they do it loki is just scoffing
at everything like how dare you like this is all
ridiculous and he calls the time keepers space
lizards because they look kind of like lizards
because the series is drawing so much energy on
things like doctor who hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy rick and morty and in those series usually
you have really big organizations that portray
themselves like they're helping everyone like we
are the law and order of the galaxy but then they
themselves the actual organizations turn out to be
pretty rotten themselves on rick and morty you
have the citadel of ricks or even the galactic
government both pretty rotten organizations that
claim to be good but they're actually being ruled
by evil morty himself now the funny connection to
the citadel of ricks too is that it's also based
on the council of reeds from marvel so they're
already borrowing from marvel it all goes back
to marvel in the end maybe someday we'll actually
get a council of reeds after they introduce the
new version of fantastic four in those movies so
that's why they have this scene with loki asking
mobius like why is it that you and the time
variants authority get to justify what you're
doing in orchestrate the lives of trillions of
people across the timeline how absurd is this
and they'll use the story of these alternate
loki's as they chase them down to examine that
like who has the right to exist what right does
the time variance authority have to get rid of
all these alternate loki's and i know everyone's
wondering if there's some big conspiracy inside
the time variance authority like if they're going
to be some big reveal or twist that they've been
infiltrated by someone and they themselves do
wind up being kind of the antagonist of the series
i'm trying to be realistic about my expectations
with characters like king the conqueror because
he would be someone who would try to take over
the time ference authority and he actually kind
of did that for a little while during a period
of about a thousand years in the distant future
that was the immortus version of king the time
keepers themselves actually made a contract with
him to basically rule over a period of about a
thousand years in the future but eventually he
got so powerful that he did start ruling over
all time from a citadel that looked a lot like
this tva citadel like at best i'm expecting
them to reveal that there's some problem
in the bureaucracy like there is something
wrong with the tva by the end of the series
that they also have to fix like they're fixing
timelines but they also have to fix the tva itself
it's sort of a watchman style question like
who watches the watchmen who polices the
police if they are the ultimate authority in
the multiverse but episode one is going to be
dropping on june 9th so for the next couple
of weeks marvel is going to be doing what they
call loki wednesdays they'll probably release new
footage every wednesday they'll probably be some
other stuff happening too i've got a whole bunch
of bonus videos planned so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of those leave all your requests to if there
are any big questions or topics that you want me
to cover we'll also get more information and more
trailers for some of the other marvel series
and movies that are coming later this year too
finally getting some marvel movies that we can
actually go see while you wait for everything
click here for all my other loki trailer videos
and all that new footage and click here for my
brand new eternals trailer video and easter
eggs and learn how they're setting up x-men
inside the mcu thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!